what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible this is the
aftermath to the viltrumite war i
imagine because it's the aftermath not a
whole lot of people will watch this
video and woba tied them because this
story is amazing okay so here's the
thing as we covered in the last video a
bargain was struck between freddie
mercury the vulture might forces and
mark and nolan right and basically
freddie mercury in them said we'll stay
here we'll intermingle right we'll
procreate with your race and then once
we're back to our at least glorious
whatever it is then things will commence
from there right it's kind of left
open-ended as to whether or not they'll
actually end up going to war with each
other and for those of you guys who have
read ahead please don't spoil
the important thing here is mark
actually meets back up with his mom and
of course he's got nolan with him and
this is kind of a big deal because this
is the first time in any real measure of
time that nolan and
his former wife have actually kind of
gotten back together or at least seen
each other for a prolonged amount of
time they saw each other for moments
previously but not for a lengthy period
of time now of course as soon as deborah
sees mark she's like where's oliver
right she immediately starts freaking
out of course that's what she's told
oliver's recovering he's alive right
he's on telescria he'll be taken care of
and that's when nolan asks her who's
paul because one of the things to keep
in mind is remember after nolan had left
mark's mom didn't necessarily bounce
around but she did find herself
attracted in a relationship with a guy
named paul and so with the two of them
kind of talking and and really becoming
close it was a little difficult for mark
to to come to terms with but uh you know
eventually he did and he's actually told
by his mom you need to go see eve right
she's not doing very well and it's
really one of those things where it's
like one you need to go talk to your
girl but two mom and dad need some alone
time
that's kind of what that is and so what
you end up getting is is really this
kind of just yelling that's sort of
going on now in reality for deborah
she's got a lot of emotion built up
right a lot of pain and a lot of anger
built up from everything that had
happened she doesn't let it all out here
in the moment instead nolan's kind of
like okay so like you took another mate
and the reason you know her response
here is it wasn't a mate right it's not
somebody that i married and even if i
did why would you be pissed you were
banging everything all over space right
how many like aliens were you
procreating with like literally mark
showed up here with another son that
belonged to you saying that like we have
to raise him right so like who are you
to get mad at me about this kind of
thing and noah's response is well i'm
not upset i'm just kind of disappointed
now for her part deborah's right here
right nolan's got no reason to be mad
right he's got no reason to even be
upset now in the middle of all that
cecil comes barging in right the last
person that needs to be here cecil comes
barging in here right immediately starts
unloading on nolan out of out of a bit
of a panic and then realizes oh yeah
that's right this guy's reformed right
so the funny thing about this is for all
the pomp and circumstance about cecil as
much as he kind of busts himself up and
makes himself up to be a big deal no
like he's almost kind of panicking and
it's kind of glad the war is not coming
the reality is humanity would have been
woefully unprepared even with cecil
creating all these invincible you know
powered beings right using all those
alternate reality versions of invincible
and kind of like reforming them uh to to
you know turn them into basically
henchmen like robotic henchmen even then
it wouldn't matter right i mean like
they would still get obliterated
especially at the hands of the forces of
all the other vulture mites but with the
war being over cease was kind of like
okay cool now at that point you pick up
with mark right the one thing you guys
want to see you pick up with mark he
flies over there he ends up coming
across adam eve he was like hey like
it's me like the war's over i'm back
everything's okay baby everything's cool
we can all get back to normal she's like
no no no don't come any closer right
he's like why and then you see adam eve
adam eve she hates the way she looks
right like adam eve what happened to you
girl i'll tell you what happened adam
eve got thick that's what happened man
adam eve got thick but nonetheless right
like like at the end of the day she
feels hideous right she sees herself as
exceedingly unattractive and hideous
mark doesn't care man he's just happy to
see his girl and i totally understand
right like i'd be the same way i'd be
like man girl i ain't seen you in like
10 months right like i don't i don't
much care and it's kind of crazy because
adam eve's been like she's been holding
on by a thread right and that's one of
the things to keep in mind is that adam
adam eve was just crazy in love with
mark right like head over heels in love
with this guy and she understood why he
had to leave like the the whole
situation between adam eve and mark like
juxtaposes the whole situation with
nolan and deborah in almost a perfect
way right that where nolan bailed out
mark had to go right mark didn't want to
go but he had to go right and he almost
kind of went with her understanding and
really did leave with her understanding
why he had to leave in the first place
but nonetheless for her it's been
extremely difficult right she recently
got her powers back which is kind of a
cool thing but for the most part the
emotional and and mental anguish of of
knowing that mark could die at any point
while he's out there in this war was
just a little too much for her to handle
because at the end of the day she
thought mark was dead right and that's
kind of the big the big issue that goes
on here is mark told her explicitly i
don't know how long i'm going to be gone
for i i could be gone for weeks i could
be gone for months i could be gone for
years right and and she you know he left
with her knowing that and she allowed
him to leave knowing that right i guess
tried to make peace with it as best as
she possibly could but she didn't know
right i mean he's on like the other side
of the universe there was no way for her
to know and the reality is her
imagination ran away with it right her
imagination ran away with the idea that
mark's dead she never heard a single
thing from him for for nolan and debbie
what you actually get here is this
interesting scenario where debbie's
highly conflicted and the reason for
this is because as she's sitting down
talking nolan she says the truth is
after seeing you again things with paul
just felt wrong not that i believe a
word of what you said that you have
feelings for me that you regret what
you've done there's no way to come back
from that and the response of nolan here
is and yet after seeing me you could no
longer stand to be with another man and
he says i wish that there was some way
to make you aware of just how much i've
missed you and the crazy thing is debbie
kind of wants to forgive him but she
can't bring herself to right that's the
conflict coming in that's the conflict
coming in right when she looks at her
husband she doesn't see the nolan that
she was in love with and had mark with
and they were going to live happily ever
after when she sees her husband she sees
a man that almost destroyed the world
fodder you know and almost killed her
son in the process and then left she
sees a villain right she sees just a
villain more so than that a villain that
betrayed her betrayed her son and
betrayed everything they stood for a man
that seemingly every word he said to her
was a lie and a lot of that's because
for nolan he didn't realize that he
actually cared about debbie until she
was gone until he left in that moment
when he left when he was talking to mark
you guys remember that whole discussion
whether you saw the show whether you saw
the the or whether you read the comic
you guys saw that discussion he looked
down on humanity humanity was lower than
him lower than he was he even saw his
you know saw his wife debbie as
something that came to like a primitive
ape right something that was just kind
of entertaining like not really
something to to laugh at but like
humanity was so primitive in relation to
the vulture minds they live for
thousands of years she'll die after 80.
and so it's one of those things where
you're kind of like you know you you see
that that she had kind of experienced
all of that right even when like the
whole video was leaked to the public
right when she saw all of that she felt
betrayed in the most egregious way
because now she knows how he actually
saw her and then here he is now saying i
missed you i loved you baby take me back
and how do you come back from that right
how do you believe that and she even
says that right nolan says i can never
take back what i did to you i understand
that all i can say is that i was
misguided lost there were so many
emotions conflicting thoughts i had
thousands of years of beliefs to
overcome you have to try and understand
the response she says is no i don't have
to understand a damn thing you ruined my
life don't you understand that you
ruined everything and she says i wish
everything could go back to the way that
it was before and the response of nolan
is things will never go back but i'll
never lie to you again but that's the
issue right that's that's the issue here
there are things that happen in a
relationship things that you will do
things that you will say maybe not
because you intend to maybe because you
intend to but your relationship will
cross a line that it cannot come back
from things will never ever ever be the
same no matter how long things go on for
the rest of your life right nolan could
just continue on with deborah until the
end of her life right because he'll
outlive her and she will never look at
him the way she did before everything
popped off in the beginning of the story
right she'll never see him the same way
she'll never hold his hand the same way
she'll never kiss him the same way
she'll never make love to him the same
way it'll never ever be the same as it
used to be it's just the way those
things are and so following that you
pick back up with mark right when he
gets back over to eve's place and she's
trying on her costume and she's like
does this make my butt look bigger and
mark's like damn son
that thick that thick thick right i mean
she looks good as hell he's like man i'm
sweetheart you don't need to lose that
weight and right mark's mark's feeling
his son
he's absolutely feeling it but you kind
of get this this bit of a discussion
going on right and things kind of return
a little bit to normal insofar as you
have eve who's over talking to mark's
mom and they're kind of you know getting
together and and things are kind of
getting back to normal a little bit and
in fact they kind of you know make some
funny jokes about mark and you know when
he was younger and and some of those
little embarrassing moments and things
along those lines but there's really a
lot of of you know familiarity and
there's a lot of comfort uh with things
going back to normal and one of the
things that happens is that mark and
adam eve actually end up going to visit
the home of immortal and duplicate right
only to find out that like they've been
procreating like rabbits right they
actually got a couple of kids going on
and they're like man you know now eve
immediately doesn't really take to the
idea of the kids being there right she's
just kind of like huh you know she seems
a little off about those kids and so of
course you know you have like mark who
thinks they're absolutely adorable you
know and and and like immortals just
like yeah man the kids like they they
eat they like to eat early right like i
hope you don't mind like we've already
made dinner and mark's like you know
that's cool man it's like they're all
kind of hanging out and they're they're
they're eating and they're having a good
time right talking about the idea of
having twins and and so on and so forth
and it's kind of interesting right just
kind of a bit of a discussion and and
just general conversation there now
there does come a point when duplicates
giving the the twins a bath and eve is
there but she doesn't want to be there
right she's she seems just so so
uncomfortable right this discussion that
they used to have they used to talk
about the idea of like you know eve and
mark having kids and settling down
buying a house you know that kind of
typical nuclear family right midwestern
american kind of thing and it's one of
those things where she's where eve just
doesn't really seem to want to have
anything to do with it anymore over the
course of these last 10 months there was
just like an extreme shift in the way
that eve saw her life playing out with
mark versus the way she sees it now but
the funny thing is it doesn't really
have much to do with mark right instead
you know when eva's asked by duplicate
are you okay she's like no i'm not i am
not okay and she races out of the room
right she basically hands the kids back
over to duplicate and takes off once she
gets outside mark's like okay what's
going on right kate said that you were
crying and that you know you're upset
like what's what's going on and where
she initially tries to kind of brush it
off right wipe her eyes clean herself up
and say i'm fine i just needed some air
mark knows her better than that and
mark's like you know no like what's
what's going on right like what's
happening you know is it something that
kate said like what's going on and and
eve stops and says no you just need to
listen what she reveals is she had an
abortion right and like the whole like
for in her mind the whole reason behind
that is she was basically pregnant at
the time that mark left right mark got
eve pregnant and she couldn't she
couldn't go through with a kid right she
couldn't do it alone she couldn't raise
a kid by herself she couldn't try to
navigate these waters by herself knowing
her husband was probably dead out there
somewhere that the the belief that her
husband died had this massive impact on
her and she aborted her child in the
process and so at that point she's not
really able to handle the situation
right it's why she ran away from the
idea of kids you know when when uh when
she was holding duplicates kids because
it reminds her of the life that she gave
up right it reminds her of something she
sacrificed here and so where mark
comforts her as best as he can at the
end of the day it's crushing for him too
right because he could could have
potentially had a child here and now he
doesn't have one and then you get
probably one of the most [ __ ] moments
of the whole story where duplicates like
i give him another weak tops right like
i love eve but she just can't keep a man
happy she's got way too many issues
right it's a [ __ ] thing to say to be
honest but at the end of the day she i
guess she doesn't say it where eve and
mark can hear her because if she did i
imagine he probably would have just beat
the hell out of her at the end of the
day the two of them you know just kind
of cry together and this really seems to
be given the the future depiction that
we saw of eve and and mark the idea that
like they just never really seem to get
together that almost seems like a
guaranteed future right one way or
another it just doesn't work out between
the two of them whether it's because
mark just never really tells her how she
feels and so she spends all this time
pining over him never moves on and finds
anybody else and ends up miserable or if
it's because of the fact that something
like this happens that drives a wedge
because the reality is when it comes to
a decision like that that can drive a
wedge between two people right the loss
of a child whether it's through abortion
or through like an early death from an
accident whatever the case is that can
kill relationships and so the results of
that is it seems like mark and eve are
kind of at an impasse and whether or not
they'll get together well we'll just
have to wait and find out but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you guys for watching i
think what i might do next is do a full
story of everything from the beginning
up to the end of the vulture might war
to kind of make sure you guys are
refreshed right because everything we
cover after this will be built on the
shoulders of the vulture mite war so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace